Hong Kong convulsed in a new night of
chaos as the city seems to be spiraling
further out of control
protesters clad in black with faces
covered again blocked roads and squared
off with police the standoff between
riot police here and anti-government
protesters lasted for about 90 minutes
it was an ebb and flow over that time
with police firing several rounds of
tear gas as well as rubber bullets until
the protesters left at the same time new
violence erupted near Hong Kong's border
with mainland China video showed a mob
of men dressed in white believed to be
members of Hong Kong's triad gangs
beating pro-democracy protesters and
passengers in a subway station with
sticks and bats the use of gangs is a
common tactic in mainland China to take
action while avoiding the use of police
the area where this happened strongly
supports Beijing residents complained it
took an hour for police to respond
nearly 50 people were injured
what started as anger over contentious
extradition bill backed by Beijing has
now evolved into a bigger war over Hong
Kong's freedoms and future we're outside
Beijing top office in Hong Kong
assembled to many of China's growing
power in this city now last night
protesters defied police orders marched
here and deface the building the
government has since condemned all forms
of violence this past weekend and says
they're going to bring everyone
responsible to justice for CBS this
morning
ramie Inocencio Hong Kong